de la Seine-Saint-Denis questeur du
Sénat on va évidemment parler de la
réforme des retraites pour commencer
avec vous puisque une mobilisation
sociale des grèves sont prévues jeudi
prochain l'initiative de l'ensemble des
syndicats ça faisait plus de 10 ans que
ça n'était pas arrivé mobilisation qui
s'annonce très très forte ce sont les
mots de Philippe Martinez le secrétaire
général de la CGT vouloir doutez cette
mobilisation je crois qu'il en doit un
droit de manifester mais il y a une
réforme qui a été proposée par le
gouvernement qui va suivre son processus
parlementaire nous pourrons amender et
que la rue s'exprime que les syndicats
manifestent c'est une chose tout à fait
normale en démocratie cela dit on doit
pas aboutir au blocage et je pense que
dans le domaine des transports dans le
domaine de l'énergie de fourniture des
carburants notamment il faut que chacun
respecte nos concitoyens et il y a aussi
déplacer
les syndicats doivent faire preuve de
responsabilités
pour nous la capacité de mener un
dialogue social de poursuivre un
processus normal ou tous les points de
vue soit inconnus et à la fin et où il y
aura une décision mais si on aboutit à
des stratégies d'affrontement je pense
que le pays va manquer un rendez-vous
avec j'ai eu une capacité à ce
moderniser aujourd'hui on voit bien que
le monde change il y a des sujets
d'équilibre financier il y a des sujets
qui les budgétaires il y a un sujet sur
les retraites sur le financement et il
faut garantir la pérennité du système de
retraite ce sont des enjeux qu'on peut
pas refuser de voir on se suppose aussi
que on essaie cette capacité de dialogue
et je crois que le gouvernement a une
responsabilité mais les partenaires
sociaux aussi et chacune et chacun
d'entre nous doit pouvoir s'exprimer on
est dans un contexte qui est pas le
meilleur il faut bien le reconnaître on
va rentrer dans le fond de cette réforme
dans quelques instants mais est-ce que
quel que soit la mobilisation
Fabien Roussel Philippe Martinez plus
d'un million de personnes le
gouvernement doit tenir coûte que coûte
ou est-ce que si la mobilisation est
trop forte il doit reculer amender
la question c'est est-ce que cette
réforme est nécessaire je crois que oui
est-ce qu'elle est équilibrée il me
semble que oui et je pense que dans le
débat parlementaire on pourra aller plus
loin voilà alors après la rue ne manif
la rue les manifestations ça ne remplace
pas le suffrage ça ne remplace pas la
légitimité des instances politiques
notamment le Parlement qui va devoir
trancher ce débat là et il devrait le
faire en responsabilité il y a des voies
d'amélioration encore mais cette réforme
est quand même moins brutale que celle
qu'on aurait pu craindre et déjà madame
borde a bougé de manière
utile sur un centre de poids je pense
aux carrières longues par exemple je
pense au niveau des retraites qui sont
servis à ceux qui ont les retraites les
plus faibles ce sera des améliorations
concrètes et il faut aussi l'entendre et
pas simplement se dire on ne peut rien
on ne doit rien changer ça n'est pas une
voix possible de ne rien changer c'était
le bon moment socialement on va parler
après du côté économique et du côté
financier mais est-ce que socialement
c'était le bon moment de faire cette
réforme ça n'est jamais le bon moment de
réformer et il est clair que on sort de
deux ans de covid c'est pas tout à fait
sorti d'ailleurs on a affronté ensemble
de crise il y a bien sûr l'inflation
j'ai fait la Légion tout à l'heure donc
tout cela pris en compte avec la guerre
à nos portes en Ukraine ça pose un
certain nombre de difficultés pour
autant se débat il a été posé il était
posé il y a plus de 2 ans depuis 1991
vous la rappelez tout à l'heure depuis
Michel Rocard chacun sait que la
question des retraites est devant nous
la démographie aussi est là donc nous
vieillissons plus longtemps ok c'est une
bonne chose et donc il faut servir les
pensions plus longtemps il faut prendre
en compte tout ça et nos voisins
européens ont fait ce genre de
changement alors quand on dit ça
quelquefois ça énerve mais simplement il
faut s'adapter au monde tel qu'il est la
France est grande lorsqu'elle sait aussi
montrer qu'elle peut s'adapter faire des
efforts ça veut dire qu'il faut que ce
soit socialement juste et là-dessus il y
a encore des marges de progression je
crois et l'autre question et vous l'avez
un peu dit c'est cette réforme est-elle
économiquement nécessaire avant de voir
ça avec vous on accueille notre
journaliste parlementaire Alex pusard
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Vincent
apocananas bonjour et Alex quand on
regarde les chiffres est-ce qu'il y a
une nécessité économique de faire cette
réforme des retraites
sur les prévisions du corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui en
septembre dernier a remis un rapport et
des prévisions sur l'avenir financier de
notre régime de retraite alors ce
rapport il se base également sur des
prévisions de croissance et de chômage
notamment en 2027 le corps prévoit par
exemple 5% de chômage et une croissance
d'un virgule 8% sachant qu'en 2027 à
partir de 2027 et bien la croissance de
la France devrait chuter alors sur cette
base quel est l'avenir financier de
notre régime des retraites et bien même
si en ce moment le régime de retraite
est excédentaire d'un milliard d'euros
dans les années à venir le déficit va se
creuser en 2027 en déficit de 12
milliards d'euros 14 milliards d'euros
pour 2030 et 21 milliards d'euros en
2035 mais il y a il y a un maire dans ce
rapport à partir de
49 dans une période entre 2039 et 2060
le régime des retraites devrait revenir
excès dentaires ça veut dire qu'il y
aura de nouveau à la fin de l'argent
dans les caisses de retraite donc on
peut dire qu'à long terme le régime des
retraites ira mieux ça veut dire pas
besoin de réformer et bien c'est ce que
disent les opposants à cette réforme des
retraites une réforme qui ne serait pas
nécessaire ou en tout cas par urgence
mais quand on accumule les déficits
pendant des dizaines d'années et bien
cela alourdit à la dette de notre régime
de retraite et donc en 2050 les déficits
cumulés des retraites s'élèveront un
niveau entre 665 milliards d'euros et
903 milliards d'euros c'est à dire entre
11% et 16% du PIB du pays ça veut dire
qu'il y a bien un sujet financier alors
Vincent apocanellas il y a un sujet
financier mais néanmoins est-ce que
cette réforme est si urgente
financièrement
d'abord il faut souligner c'est que les
prévisions du corps sont basées sur des
hypothèses de croissance qui sont quand
même très optimistes cette année la
Banque de France nous dit qu'on aura 03
04% de croissance et là c'est basé sur
1,8 ensuite c'est basé sur une hypothèse
de taux de chômage qui serait très
faible 5% on rêve d'y arriver mais on
n'est pas encore et très loin de là on
est au-dessus de de 6 et demi 7
aujourd'hui donc il faut être très
prudent ces prévisions me paraissent un
peu un petit peu optimiste ensuite il
faut à la fois permettre d'assurer le
financement de nos retraites pour
permettre la pérennité du système dans
lequel nous sommes par un système par
répartition et non pas par
capitalisation et il faut aussi avoir à
l'esprit que si nous voulons résoudre
nos déficits de déficits publics
travailler plus c'est une des solutions
qui permettra de dégager plus de
richesses plus de ressources pour l'État
et qui permettra d'assurer la pérennité
tout le système social auquel nous
sommes attachés donc derrière cette
réforme des retraites selon où il y a
quand même cette logique de faire
travailler plus les français pour
augmenter notre croissance et faire
mieux vivre le pays ok deux objectifs le
premier c'est évidemment des suelles
pérennité de nos retraites c'est très
important pour les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui de savoir que demain ils
pourront avoir une retraite qui leur
sera servi dans de bonnes conditions et
l'objectif c'est de pas baisser
d'ailleurs les pensions au contraire
c'est des améliorer pour une part ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
il faut pas le masquer en France on a un
problème de déficit public et si on
travaille plus on n'a pas touché au 35
heures si on travaille plus longtemps ça
générera un petit peu plus de richesse
alors il y a un sujet c'est de permettre
que ceux qui vont travailler plus
longtemps puissent trouver leur place
dans l'entreprise dans la société dans
le travail et aujourd'hui on a trop
tendance à estimer que à un certain âge
56 57 ans et bien on vous propose la
voie de la sortie et il faut maintenant
réfléchir à la manière de gérer la
pénibilité au travail de gérer le fait
que les plus âgés entre guillemets on
est vraiment pas âgés à ce stage là
quand même mais puisse continuer à
travailler et que les entreprises aussi
choisissent investir sur suffisamment de
choses dans la réforme parce que sur
l'emploi le gouvernement veut améliorer
l'emploi des seniors pour le moment il y
a un index mais qui n'est pas
contraignant pas de sanction pour les
entreprises pour vous c'est suffisant
donc je crois que c'était pas suffisant
c'est tout l'enjeu de la réforme et
c'est le point qu'il faut qu'il faut
réussir je crois qu'il y a un dialogue
qu'il faut ouvrir il est parti d'une
association et les entreprises là-dessus
et j'espère qu'on pourra demander sur ce
point-là alors avec des sanctions et des
contraintes pour vous un moment donné il
faudra passer un système qui soit
vraiment incitatif et si besoin à des
sanctions est-ce qu'on peut aussi
envisager une hausse des cotisations des
employeurs on le rappelle en ce régime
par réparation par répartition et
financé par les cotisations des salariés
et des employeurs pourquoi ne pas les
faire participer un petit peu à l'effort
ces employeurs alors il y a je crois
vraiment une petite toute petite hausse
mais très faible c'est vrai alors il
faut qu'on veille aussi à la
compétitivité des entreprises parce que
on est dans un monde de compétition
malheureusement on dirais-je et si on
alourdit encore la charge de
l'entreprise qui est forte on aura moins
d'emplois
grande capacité à
aussi exporter et on sait bien qu'on a
un problème c'est le déficit extérieur
c'est la France appauvrit parce que elle
ne produit pas assez aujourd'hui et
parce que donc elle achète à l'extérieur
et donc ça fait on a difficile du
commerce extérieur et donc la France au
fond on voit sa richesse à l'étranger
pour acheter des biens donc ça c'est un
sujet veillant à la compétitivité c'est
vrai que cette réforme elle est basée
sur deux curseurs l'allongement de de la
durée de cotisation et puis l'âge de
départ qui est décalé mais ça c'est ce
qui permet aussi d'assurer l'efficacité
du système on ne touche pas aux
cotisations effectivement ni des
salariés ni des entreprises quasiment
pas en tout cas et ensuite on ne baisse
pas le niveau des pensions ce qui était
je crois le point majeur et encore une
fois il y a quelques améliorations qui
sont notables pour les petites retraites
et là-dessus il faut arriver il y a une
amélioration qui est proposée par la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat Sophie prima c'est
matrice les républicain elle dit pour
trouver une porte de sortie à la
mobilisation sociale qui s'annonce il
faudrait peut-être ralentir le rythme du
report de l'âge légal qui est prévu à 64
ans en 2030 on pourrait peut-être
arriver à 64 ans un petit peu plus tard
que 2030 ça peut être une amélioration
une solution je crois qu'il y a un vrai
sujet là-dessus parce que ceux qui sont
là dans les années 60 au fond et puis
surtout disons dans la tranche 65 68
cela vont entre guillemets payer le prix
de la réforme c'est à dire se retrouver
avec deux ans de plus presque à peu près
un an si on est en 67 par exemple on va
on va avoir un an et neuf mois de plus
avant d'arriver à la retraite donc là
c'est vrai que cette partie là de la
population ce sont un peu un peu visé
donc on peut réfléchir à un centre de
modalités mais après il faut que la
réforme soit efficace
il y a des gens qui à l'heure actuelle
sont proches de la retraite et qui sont
concernés par la réforme il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de délai est-ce que il faut
que les gens que les gens qui sont
proches de la retraite ne soient pas
concernés et quel délai est-ce que ça
doit être les gens qui sont à 3 ans à 5
ans à 6 ans de la retraite qui doivent
en être exclus il y a un délai
aujourd'hui au sens où simplement ça va
être trois mois par trois mois
supplémentaires etc on peut on peut
réfléchir à un étalement voilà mais
n'oublions pas quand même que l'idée
c'est pas d'y revenir trop souvent la
dernière fois on est passé à 62 ans et
la question était est-ce que c'était 72
ou 63 bon bah du coup ça avance à chaque
fois le rythme des réformes successives
il faut certes s'adapter à la
démographie et aux conditions
économiques globales mais on peut
moduler pour rendre tout ça acceptable
c'est vrai que il y a un prix pour cette
génération là
disons 65 68 ceux qui sont pas dans 65
68 ans particuliers
on peut y réfléchir mais
on peut donner des signaux il faudra de
toute façon c'est vrai trouver une issue
après la mobilisation moi je veux que ce
soit une mobilisation que les parties
fassent entendre leur voix mais que on
aboutissent pas à un bloc et que ceux
d'entre nous qui ont besoin s'est
déplacer en particulier
ceux qui utilisent leur véhicule et qui
se font des soucis aujourd'hui sur la
présidente des sens par exemple tout
cela peut être rassuré on doit être une
démocratie mature et surtout c'est un
test pour le pays est-ce que nous avons
la capacité de nous adapter autant
d'aujourd'hui la France est forte et
elle est belle lorsqu'elle sait
s'adaptée au monde et porter aussi sa
voix mais il faut savoir s'adapter aussi
un dernier mot sur le débat
parlementaire surtout à l'Assemblée
nationale parce que la patronne des
Verts dit vouloir transformer
l'Assemblée en ZAD les députés de la
France insoumise on dit vouloir déposer
1000 amendements chacun sa ferait 75000
amendements est-ce que vous pensez que
le débat parlementaire pour avoir lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que chacun chacune des
deux chambres regarde ce texte en
responsabilité d'abord nous avons
aujourd'hui quand même des axes de
réforme il nous attendons d'avoir le
texte précis ça viendra en conseil des
ministres dans une dizaine de jours et
donc à ce moment là pourra réfléchir
amender amender n'est pas bloqué et donc
les les responsables politiques et nos
collègues députés en particulier ont un
devoir c'est de montrer que nous sommes
force de proposition avec un esprit de
responsabilité au bout d'un moment il
faudrait bien tranché le sujet parce
qu'il est devant nous et qu'on peut pas
éternellement le repousser je pense
qu'il y a un stress aussi à cette idée
que on ne soit pas capable d'avancer et
de faire des choix sur des sujets
majeurs complexes c'est le cas des
retraites et ça sera demain le cas
finalement de la dette publique
globalement et finalement le fait que le
gouvernement est donné une copie ça peut
aussi enlever du stress parce que
perpétuellement ne pas savoir c'est
aussi un problème que de vivre avec ça
voilà donc la France a rendez-vous avec
elle même là-dessus
merci Alex à tout à l'heure on parlera
de l'aide aux femmes victimes de
violences conjugales
nous direz ce qu'il en est ce sera dans
une demi-heure on va voir l'actualité
dans nos régions bah du côté de Nice on
retrouve de nikaro bonjour Denis merci
d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions du groupe Nice-Matin et Denis
à lire dans vos pages aujourd'hui une
longue interview du maire de Nice et
président de la Métropole Nice Côte
d'Azur Christian Estrosi oui
effectivement grande interview de
rentrée de de Christian Estrosi le maire
est président de la métropole s'exprime
sur les grands sujets du moment il y en
a un qui est en train de de monter c'est
la question des finances de la métropole
la métropole a engagé beaucoup de grands
projets investissements lourds et
aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre de
clignotants qui sont à l'orange Waro au
rouge alors Christian Estrosi ne nie pas
les difficultés il confirme que la
métropole se rapproche du niveau maximal
d'emprunt et il évoque
revient sur les raisons de cette de
cette situation et notamment
l'accumulation des crises la crise
sanitaire pour laquelle la métropole de
Nice a engagé beaucoup de dépenses elle
a été très active à l'époque la tempête
Alex qui a frappé les vallées niçoise et
qui a nécessité d'engager des dépenses
extrêmement importantes et puis bien
entendu comme pour l'ensemble des
collectivités françaises la hausse des
prix de l'énergie alors Christie Estrosi
annonce qu'il va devoir faire des des
arbitrages et il lance un appel un appel
au gouvernement dont il est dont il est
plutôt proche il souhaite que le
gouvernement puisse aider la métropole
de Nice il écarte pour le moment
l'hypothèse d'une augmentation des
impôts mais entre les lignes on comprend
que si l'aide du gouvernement n'arrive
pas ça pourrait être un choix dans les
dans les mois qui viennent parmi les
sujets abordés aussi Christian Estrosi
s'ex sur la mise en place de la zone
affaiblissement à Nice alors on le voit
ici il n'y a pas de zèle particulier de
la de la ville par rapport à la ZFE
notamment les policiers municipaux ne
verbalisent pas et Christian Estrosi
explique qu'il ne veut pas sanctionner
les gens les plus modestes et qu'ils
préfèrent mettre en place des des
solutions pour aider les gens à changer
de véhicule alors d'où ma question à
Vincent apocanellas on voit que la
question des edfe monte un petit peu
partout en France alors est-ce que le
gouvernement s'y est bien pris et est-ce
qu'on n'a pas là avec les zones
affaiblissement un sujet explosif et
peut-être aussi explosif à terme que
celui de la réforme des retraites
oh c'est un sujet particulièrement
difficile c'est clair moi j'ai siéger la
métropole du Grand Paris il y a quelques
années de ça et déjà le sujet était sur
la table on voit bien que pour ceux de
nos compatriotes qui ont des véhicules
anciens et pour les plus modestes il y a
un vrai sujet qui le permettre de
financer l'achat de véhicules qui soit
moins émetteur par rapport à tout ça le
ministre a fait il y a quelques temps
des déclarations sur l'accompagnement
aussi des collectivité parce qu'il va
falloir comment on contrôle mais c'est
un enjeu de santé publique donc il faut
trouver la façon d'avancer maintenant
là-dessus concrètement parce que là
aussi c'est un sujet comme ça qui court
depuis des années et il y a une attente
de nos compatriotes mais ça doit être un
tout transport public à développer aide
aux particuliers et puis voir comment on
accompagne les collectivités alors c'est
avec la difficulté et c'est ce que dit
Christian Estrosi finalement c'est que
les collectivités ont le mauvais rôle
celui verbalisé et ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas très simple donc je sais que le
ministre monsieur bonne a fait des
déclarations et annoncer un centre de
mesure d'accompagnement et je crois il
faut vraiment un dialogue là dessus pour
pour avancer mais il me semble que nous
sommes aussi dans une stratégie
environnementale et que émettre moins de
CO2 c'est aussi préserver la santé des
plus fragiles il nous faut avancer
là-dessus vous savez quand on touche à
la voiture c'est toujours compliqué
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'il
y a une colère sociale qui a un colère
qui est en train de mettre dans ce pays
autour de ses Adeps je pense que oui il
y a un risque maintenant de la peur
n'évite pas le danger et surtout les
sujets sur les sujets des retraits qu'on
a abordés précédemment mais aussi sur le
sujet que vous abordez la à l'instant du
financement des collectivités locales de
la baisse des investissements des
collectivités locales en raison
notamment d'augmentation des coûts des
fluides par exemple aussi de la
restauration scolaire qui qui voit ses
coups vraiment augmenter et
collectivités ont des difficultés donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a dans les petits
villages comme dans les grandes communes
à un certain nombre de risques et nous
concitoyens le voit bien et cette
affaire des feux est à traiter aussi
avec doigté mais pour autant c'est le
même débat que tout à l'heure il nous
faut savoir Ré savoir prendre des
mesures qui sont des vrais changements
accompagner chacun c'est toujours ce
qu'est d'ailleurs compliqué c'est que
finalement on finit par voter des
mesures en matière environnementale et
puis on les déconnecte de leur mise en
œuvre et donc là dessus il y a un vrai
sujet je pense qu'il faut que les
ministres aussi les gouvernement aille
plus avant avec tous ceux qui mettent à
neuf sur le terrain et il y a un vrai
travail dessus il faut des assises il
faut un dialogue sur cette affaire de
mise en place des élèves c'est un sujet
de santé publique mais effectivement ces
contraignant comme les 80 km/h merci
Denis Caro merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous on revoilà une de nuit ce
matin Estrosi s'explique c'est donc à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Denis carreau de nous en avoir parlé on
va voir l'actualité une des actualités
en Seine-Saint-Denis on va parler des
Jeux Olympiques Vincent kapokanel est-ce
que c'est Jeux olympiques sont une
aubaine pour votre département alors je
crois que c'est une chance parce que
Paris aurait pu confisquer les jeux si
je puis dire et département nous avons
aussi réussi à ce qu'il n'y ait pas que
pleine commune pas que les alentours de
Saint-Denis Saint-Ouen et l'île
Saint-Denis mais ça va aussi jusqu'à du
nid jusqu'au Bourget j'ai beaucoup
travaillé à l'époque commère du Bourget
et dont on parlementaire pour cela et
j'étais hier au vœu des anciens au
Bourget par exemple et j'étais l'autre
jour à du nid pour les vœux du maire
tout ceci est attendu c'est un potentiel
de transformation avec comme on dit un
héritage c'est-à-dire son équipements
qui arrivent donc c'est une chance pour
ce département et je crois que le
travail là-dessus avec la Ville de Paris
a été très positif maintenant il faut
réussir les jeux c'est un enjeu
d'intérêt national c'est l'image de la
France à l'étranger et c'est une belle
image pour le sport aussi et pour la
cohésion du pays que de savoir se
rassembler parfois le monde entier va
nous regarder lorsque on a regardé la
Coupe du Monde et bien chacun a regardé
si oui ou non c'était bien organisé avec
les débats qu'on connaît évidemment mais
en France on les a fait des jeux je
crois exemplaires il faut qu'il soit
sobre il faut que financièrement tienne
dans la maquette budgétaire c'est ce que
j'avais demandé est-ce que ça vous
inquiète est-ce que vous pensez que tout
sera prêt à temps il y a quel prix
surtout est-ce que vous redoutez des
dérives financières alors il faut aussi
prendre en compte un centre de dérive
qui sont celles de l'inflation il y a un
élément majeur et on aura bientôt un
projet de loi d'ailleurs sur ce point-là
qui est
sécurité et la sécurité donc voilà
là-dessus il faut que les personnes
s'arrête de stabilité et et disent les
moyens dont il a dont il a besoin mais
on doit rester dans les enveloppes aussi
clairement possible et sinon il faut que
l'État nous explique où sont les où sont
les difficultés et les raisons chacun
peut les comprendre
la semaine dernière et il alerte
notamment sur le dispositif de sécurité
autour de la cérémonie d'ouverture c'est
une grande cérémonie d'ouverture qui
sera tout le long de la scène des
centaines de milliers de personnes
attendues est-ce que le comité olympique
a eu un peu la folie des grandeurs selon
vous
c'est pas le plus sobre non plus c'est
un peu un défi la France aime bien se
lancer des défis et montrer au monde
entier être créatif donc voilà il y a un
enjeu là-dessus
j'aurais pas forcément pris cette option
là moi il me semble que une cérémonie au
Stade de France avait du sens aussi mais
l'arbitrage maintenant je crois qu'il
faut le tenir allez on est un peu
patriotisme dans ma réponse c'est une
dernière question
question sur un autre sujet qui concerne
le Sénat parce que vous allez être
désigner cette semaine rapporteur de la
mission d'information sur le
biocarburant l'hydrogène vert sur quoi
vous allez travailler
je vais concret mon groupe a proposé ça
sur sur ma proposition c'est-à-dire
comment assurer une filière ou on
travaille sur les carburants
synthétiques durables les biocarburants
l'hydrogène vert il faut être concret
quand on parle de transition écologique
chacun dit il faut faire ceci il faut
faire cela moi j'ai pris un axe clair à
savoir comment la France pourra
s'approvisionner en énergie verte et
donc c'est un vrai sujet les États-Unis
par exemple
on mise beaucoup sur ces carburants 10
synthétiques et sur l'hydrogène vert il
faut pas uniquement se propulser à
l'hydrogène il faut que ça un hydrogène
vert et donc là dessus il y a un sujet
pour avoir de l'électricité décarbonée
et c'est ce qu'on va essayer de regarder
la France là dessus il va y avoir un
problème de souveraineté là-dessus mon
idée c'est de créer une filière
souveraine française qu'on soit pas
dépendant des autres il y a eu des
appels à manifestation d'intérêt il y a
eu un centre de choses mais je trouve
que la filière énergétique n'est pas au
point là-dessus et donc on fera des
propositions mission va se constituer je
serai j'espère désigner la semaine
prochaine là-dessus et donc on va
pouvoir travailler on va se donner
quelques mois mais l'idée c'est de
ressortir avec si possible des
propositions concrètes et que on traite
ce sujet là voilà les biocarburants
c'est que c'est difficile les carburants
synthétiques durables ça peut marcher
l'hydrogène vers c'est aussi un enjeu
mais encore faut-il que on est ces
énergies vertes et pas simplement avoir
la technologie merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires on va
parler
des parce que je ne sais pas si vous le
savez mais aujourd'hui c'est censé être
le jour le plus déprimant de l'année
c'est pas votre cas je commence avec
vous donc tout va bien
c'est gentil et vous allez voir que les
journaux régionaux du centre de la
France tentent aussi de mettre leur
lecteur de bonne humeur et d'éviter la
déprime on verra ça avec Julien Bonnefoy
qui est chargé de ses journaux ce sera
dans 20 minutes merci beaucoup
tout de suite on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan qui nous rejoint